[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: Well, so far we've
invented enough programming to
do some very complicated
things.
And you surely learned
a lot about
programming at this point.
You've learned almost all the
most important tricks that
usually don't get taught to
people until they have had a
lot of experience.
For example, data directed
programming is a major trick,
and yesterday you also saw
an interpreted language.
We did this all in a computer
language, at this point, where
there was no assignment
statement.
And presumably, for those of you
who've seen your Basic or
Pascal or whatever, that's
usually considered the most
important thing.
Well today, we're going to
do some thing horrible.
We're going to add an assignment
statement.
And since we can do all these
wonderful things without it,
why should we add it?
An important thing to understand
is that today we're
going to, first of all, have a
rule, which is going to always
be obeyed, which is the only
reason we ever add a feature
to our language is because
there is a good reason.
And the good reason is going to
boil down to the ability,
you now get an ability to break
a problem into pieces
that are different sets of
pieces then you could have
broken it down without that,
give you another means of
decomposition.
However, let's just start.
Let me quick begin by reviewing
the kind of language
that we have now.
We've been writing what's called
functional programs.
And functional programs are
a kind of encoding of
mathematical truths.
For example, when we look at the
factorial procedure that
you see on the slide here, it's
basically two clauses.
If n is one, the result is
one, otherwise n times
factorial n minus one.
That's factorial of n.
Well, that is factorial of n.
And written down in some other
obscure notation that you
might have learned in calculus
classes, mathematical logic,
what you see there is if n
equals one, for the result of
n factorial is one, otherwise,
greater than one, n factorial
is n times n minus
one factorial.
True statements, that's
the kind of
language we've been using.
And whenever we have true
statements of that sort, there
is a kind of, a way of
understanding how they work
which is that such processes
can be involved by
substitution.
And so we see on the second
slide here, that the way we
understand the execution implied
by those statements in
arranged in that order, is
that you do successive
substitutions of arguments for
formal parameters in the body
of a procedure.
This is basically a sequence
of equalities.
Factorial four is four times
factorial three.
That is four times three times
factorial of two and so on.
We're always preserving truth.
Even though we're talking about
true statements, there
might be more than one
organization of these true
statements to describe the
computation of a particular
function, the computation
of the value of
a particular function.
So, for example, looking
at the next one here.
Here is a way of looking
at the sum of n and m.
And we did this one by
a recursive process.
It's the increment of the sum
of the decrement of n and m.
And, of course, there is some
piece of mathematical logic
here that describes that.
It's the increment of the sum
of the decrement of n and m,
just like that.
So there's nothing particularly
magic about that.
And, of course, if we can also
look at an iterative process
for the same, a program that
evolves an iterative process,
for the same function.
These are two things that
compute the same answer.
And we have equivalent
mathematical truths that are
arranged there.
And just the way you arrange
those truths determine the
particular process.
In the way choose and arrange
them determines the process
that's evolved.
So we have the flexibility
of talking about both the
function to be computed,
and the method
by which it's computed.
So it's not clear
we need more.
However, today I'm going
to this awful thing.
I'm going to introduce this
assignment operation.
Now, what is this?
Well, first of all, there is
going to be another kind of
kind of statement, if you
will, in a programming
language called Set!
Things that do things like
assignment, I'm going to put
exclamation points after.
We'll talk about what that
means in a second.
The exclamation point, again
like question mark, is an
arbitrary thing we attach to the
symbol which is the name,
has no significance
to the system.
The only significance is to me
and you to alert you that this
is an assignment of some sort.
But we're going to set a
variable to a value.
And what that's going to mean
is that there is a time at
which something happens.
Here's a time.
If I have time going this
way, it's a time access.
Time progresses by walking
down the page.
Then an assignment is the
first thing we have that
produces the difference between
a before and an after.
All the other programs that
we've written, that have no
assignments in them, the order
in which they were evaluated
didn't matter.
But assignment is special, it
produces a moment in time.
So there is a moment before the
set occurs and after, such
that after this moment in time,
the variable has the
value, value.
Independent of what value
it had before, set!
changes the value
of the variable.
Until this moment, we had
nothing that changed.
So, for example, one of the
things we can think of is that
the procedures we write for
something like factorial are
in fact pretty much identical
to the function factorial.
Factorial of four, if I write
fact4, independent of what
context it's in, and independent
of how many times
I write it, I always get
the same answer.
It's always 24.
It's a unique map from the
argument to the answer.
And all the programs we've
written so far are like that.
However, once I have assignment,
that isn't true.
So, for example, if I were to
define count to be one.
And then I'm going to define
also a procedure, a simple
procedure called demo, which
takes argument x and does the
following operations.
It first sets x to x plus one.
My gosh, this looks just
like FORTRAN, right--
in a funny syntax.
And then add to x count, Oh,
I just made a mistake.
I want to say, set! count
to one plus count.
It's this thing defined here.
And then plus x count.
Then I can try this procedure.
Let's run it.
So, suppose I get a prompt
and I say, demo three.
Well, what happens here?
The first thing that happens
is count is currently one.
Currently, there is a time.
We're talking about time.
x gets three.
At this moment, I say,
oh yes, count is
incremented, so count is two.
two plus three is five.
So the answer I get
out is five.
Then I say, demo of
say, three again.
What do I get?
Well, now count is two, it's
not one anymore, because I
have incremented it.
But now I go through this
process, three goes into x,
count becomes one plus count,
so that's three now.
The sum of those two is six,
so the answer is six.
And what we see is the same
expression leads to two
different answers, depending
upon time.
So demo is not a function,
does not compute a
mathematical function.
In fact, you could also see why
now, of course, this is
the first place where the
substitution model
isn't going to work.
This kills the substitution
model dead.
You know, with quotation there
were some little problems that
a philosopher might notice
with the substitutions,
because you have to worry about
what deductions you can
make when you substitute into
quotes, if you're allowed to
do that at all.
But here the substitution
model is dead, can't do
anything at all.
Because, supposing I wanted to
use a substitution model to
consider substituting
for count?
Well, my gosh, if I substitute
for here and here, they're
different ones.
It's not the same
count any more.
I get the wrong answer.
The substitution model is
a static phenomenon that
describes things that are true
and not things that change.
Here, we have truths
that change.
OK, Well, before I give you
any understanding of this,
this is very bad.
Now, we've lost our model
of computation.
Pretty soon, I'm going to have
to build you a new model of
computation.
But ours plays with this, just
now, in an informal sense.
Of course, what you already
see is that when I have
something like assignment, the
model that we're going to need
is different from the model that
we had before in that the
variables, those symbols like
count, or x are no longer
going to refer to the values
they have, but rather to some
sort of place where the
value restored.
We're going to have to think
that way for a while.
And it's going to be a
very bad thing and
cause a lot of trouble.
And so, as I said, the very fact
that we're inventing this
bad thing, means that there had
better be a good reason
for it, otherwise, just
a waste of time
and a lot of effort.
Let's just look at some
of it just to play.
Supposing we write down the
functional version, functional
meaning in the old style,
of factorial by
an iterative process.
Factorial of n, we're going to
iterate of m and i, which says
if i is greater than n, then
the result is m, otherwise,
the result of iterating the
product of i and m.
So m is going to be the product
that I'm accumulating.
m is the product.
And the count I'm going
to increase by one.
Plus, ITER, ELSE,
COND, define.
I'm going to start this up.
And these days, you should
have no trouble reading
something like this.
What I have here is a
product there being
accumulated and a counter.
I start them up both at one.
I'm going to buzz the counter
up, i goes to i plus one every
time around.
But that's only our putting a
time on the process, each of
this is just a set of
truths, true rules.
And m is going to get a new
values of i and m, i times m
each time around, and eventually
i is going to be
bigger than n, in which case,
the answer's going to be m.
Now, I'm speaking to you,
use time in this.
That's just because I know
how the computer works.
But I didn't have to.
This could be a purely
mathematical description at
this point, because
substitution
will work for this.
But let's set right down a
similar sort of program, using
the same algorithm, but
with assignments.
So this is called the
functional version.
I want to write down an
imperative version.
Factorial of n.
I'm going to create
my two variables.
Let i initialize itself to one,
and m be initialized to
one, similar.
We'll create a loop which has
COND greater than i, and if i
is greater than n, we're done.
And the result is m, the product
I'm accumulating.
Otherwise, I'm going to write
down three things to do.
I'm going to set!
m to the product of i and m,
set! i to the sum of i and
one, and go around
the loop again.
Looks very familiar to you
FORTRAN programmers.
ELSE, COND, define, funny
syntax though.
Start the loop up, and
that's the program.
Now, this program, how
do we think about it?
Well, let's just say what
we're seeing here.
There are two local variables,
i and m, that have been
initialized to one.
Every time around the loop, I
test to see if i is greater
than n, which is the input
argument, and if so, the
result is the product being
accumulated in m.
However, if it's not the end of
the loop, if I'm not done,
then what I'm going to do is
change the product to be the
result of multiplying i times
the current product.
Which is sort of what
we were doing here.
Except here I wasn't changing.
I was making another copy,
because the substitution model
says, you copy the body of the
procedure with the arguments
substituted for the
formal parameters.
Here I'm not worried about
copying, here I've changed the
value of m.
I also then change the value
of i to i plus one, and go
buzzing around.
Seems like essentially the same
program, but there are
some ways of making
errors here that
didn't exist until today.
For example, if I were to do
the horrible thing of not
being careful in writing my
program and interchange those
two assignments, the
program wouldn't
compute the same function.
I get a timing error because
there's a dependency that m
depends upon having the
last value of i.
If I try to i first, then I've
got the wrong value of i when
I multiply by m.
It's a bug that wasn't available
until this moment,
until we introduced something
that had time in it.
So, as I said, first we need a
new model of computation, and
second, we have to be damn good
reason for doing this
kind of ugly thing.
Are there any questions?
Speak loudly, David.
AUDIENCE: I'm confused about,
we've introduced set now, but
we had let before and
define before.
I'm confused about the
difference between the three.
Wouldn't define work in the same
situation as set if you
introduced it a bit?
PROFESSOR: No, define is
intended for setting something
once the first time,
for making it.
You've never seen me write on a
blackboard two defines in a
row whose intention was to
change the old value of some
variable to a new one.
AUDIENCE: Is that by
convention or--
PROFESSOR: No, it's intention.
The answer is that, for
example, internal to a
procedure, two defines in a row
are illegal, two defines
in a row of the same variable.
x can't be defined twice.
Whether or not a system catches
that error is a
different question, but I
legislate to you that define
happens once on anything.
Now, indeed, in interactive
debugging, we intend that you
interacting with your computer
will redefine things, and so
there's a special
exception made
for interactive debugging.
But define is intended to mean
to set up something which will
be forever that value
after that point.
It's as if all the defines were
done at the beginning.
In fact, the only legal place
to put a define in Scheme,
internal to a procedure, is
just at the beginning of a
lambda expression,
the beginning of
the body of a procedure.
Now, let of course does nothing
like either of that.
I mean, if you look at what's
happening with a let, this
happens again exactly once.
It sets up a context where i and
m are values one and one.
That context exists throughout
this scope, this
region of the program.
However, you don't think of that
let as setting i again.
It doesn't change it.
i never changes because
of the let.
i gets created because of let.
In fact, the let is a
very simple idea.
Let does nothing more, Let a
variable one to have value
one; I'll write this down a
little bit more neatly; Let's
write, var one have value, the
value of expression e1, and
variable two, have this value
of the expression e2, in an
expression e3, is the same thing
as a procedure of var
one and var two, the formal
parameters, and e3 being the
body, where var one is bound
to the value of e1, and var
two gets the value of e2.
So this is, in fact, a perfectly
understandable thing
from a substitution
point of view.
This is really the same
expression written in two
different ways.
In fact, the way the actual
system works is this gets
translated into this before
anything happens.
AUDIENCE: OK, I'm still unclear
as then what makes the
difference between a
let and a define.
They could--
PROFESSOR: A define is a
syntactic sugar, whereby,
essentially a bunch of variables
get created by lets
and then set up once.
OK, time for the first
break, I think.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well let's see.
I now have to rebuild the model
of computation, so you
understand how some such
mechanical mechanism could
work that can do what we've
just talked about.
I just recently destroyed
your substitution model.
Unfortunately, this model is
significantly more complicated
than the substitution model.
It's called the environment
model.
And I'm going to have to
introduce some terminology,
which is very good terminology
for you to know anyway.
It's about names.
And we're going to give names
to the kinds of names things
have and the way those
names are used.
So this is a meta-description,
if you will.
Anyway, there is a pile of an
unfortunate terminology here,
but we're going to need this
to understand what's called
the environment model.
We're about to do a little bit
of boring, dog-work here.
Let's look at the first
transparency.
And we see a description
of a word called bound.
And we're going to say that a
variable, v, is bound in an
expression, e, if the meaning
of e is unchanged by the
uniform replacement of a
variable w, not occurring in
e, for every occurrence
of v in e.
Now that's a long sentence, so,
I think, I'm going to have
to say a little bit about
that before we even fool
around at all here.
Bound variables we're
talking about here.
And you've seen lots of them.
You may not know that you've
seen lots of them.
Well, I suppose in your logic
you saw a logical variables
like, for every x there exists
a y such that p is true of x
and y from your calculus
class.
This variable, x, and this
variable, y, are bound,
because the meaning of this
expression does not depend
upon the particular letters I
used to describe x and y.
If I were to change the w for x,
then said for every w there
exists a y such that p is true
of w and y, it would be the
same sentence.
That's what it means.
Or another case of this that
you've seen is integral say,
from 0 to one of dx over
one plus x square.
Well that's something you
see all the time.
And this x is a bound
variable.
If I change that to a
t, the expression is
still the same thing.
This is a 1/4 of the arctan of
one or something like that.
Yes, that's the arctan of one.
So bound variables are actually
fairly common, for
those of you who have played
a bit with mathematics.
Well, let's go into the
programming world.
Instead of the quantifier being
something like, for
every, or there exists, or
integral, a quantifier is a
symbol that binds a variable.
And we are going to use the
quantifier lambda as being the
essential thing that
binds variables.
And so we have some nice
examples here like that
procedure of one argument
y which does
the following thing.
It calls the procedure of one
argument x, which multiplies x
by y, and applies
that to three.
That procedure has the property
there of two bound
variables in it, x and y.
This quantifier, lambda here,
binds this y, and this
quantifier, lambda,
binds that x.
Because, if I were to take an
arbitrary symbol does not
occur in this expression like w
and replace all y's with w's
in this expression, the
expression is still the same,
the same procedure.
And this is an important idea.
The reason why we had such
things like that is a kind of
modularity.
If two people are writing
programs, and they work
together, it shouldn't matter
what names they use internal
to their own little machines
that they're building.
And so, what I'm really telling
you there, is that,
for example, this is equivalent
to that procedure
of one argument y which uses
that procedure of one argument
d which multiplies z by y.
Because nobody cares what
I used in here.
It's a nice example.
On the other hand, I have some
variables that are not bound.
For example, that procedure
of one argument x which
multiplies x by y.
In this case, y is not bound.
Supposing y had the value three,
and z had the value
four, then this procedure
would be the thing that
multiplies its argument
by three.
If I were to replace every
instance of y with z, I would
have a different procedure
which multiplies every
argument that's given by four.
And, in fact, we have a name
for such a variable.
Here, we say that a variable, v,
is free in the expression,
e, if the meaning of the
expression, e, is changed by
the uniform replacement of a
variable, w, not occurring in
e for every occurrence
of v and e.
So that's why this variable
over here,
y, is a free variable.
And so free variables
in this expression--
And other examples of that is
that procedure of one argument
y, which is just what we had
before, which uses that
procedure of one argument x
that multiplies x by y--
use that on three.
This procedure has
a free variable
in it which is asterisk.
See, because, if that has
a normal meaning of
multiplication, then if I were
to replace uniformly all
asterisks with pluses, then the
meaning of this expression
would change.
That's what you mean
by a free variable.
So, so far you've learned some
logician words which describe
the way names are used.
Now, we have to do a little bit
more playing around here,
a little bit more.
I want to tell you about the
regions are over which
variables are defined.
You see, we've been very
informal about this up till
now, and, of course, many of you
have probably understood
very clearly or most of you,
that the x that's being
declared here is defined
only in here.
This x is the defined only in
here, and this y is defined
only in here.
We have a name for
such an idea.
It's called a scope.
And let me give you another
piece of terminology.
It's a long story.
If x is a bound variable in
e, then there is a lambda
expression where it is bound.
So the only way you can get a
bound variable ultimately is
by lambda expression.
Then you may worry, does
define quite an
exception to this?
And it turns out, we could
always arrange things so you
don't need any defines.
And we'll see that in a while.
It's a very magical thing.
So define really can go away.
The really, only thing that
makes names is lambda .
That's its job.
And what's so amazing about
a lot of things is you can
compute with only lambda.
But, in any case, a lambda
expression has a place where
it declares a variable.
We call it the formal parameter
list or the bound
variable list. We say that the
lambda expression binds--
so it's a verb--
binds the variables declared in
it's found variable list.
In addition, those parts of
the expression where the
variable is defined, which was
declared by some declaration,
is called the scope
of that variable.
So these are scopes.
This is the scope of y.
And this is the scope of x--
that sort of thing.
OK, well, now we have enough
terminology to begin to
understand how to make a new
model for computation, because
the key thing going on here
is that we destroyed the
substitution model, and we now
have to have a model that
represents the names as
referring to places.
Because if we are going to
change something, then we have
a place where it's stored.
You see, if a name only refers
to a value, and if I tried to
change the name's meaning,
well, that's not clear.
There's nothing that is
the place that that
name referred to.
How am I really saying it?
There is nothing shared
among all of the
instances of that name.
And what we really mean,
by a name, is that we
fan something out.
We've given something a name,
and you have it, and you have
it, because I'm given you a
reference to it, and I've
given you a reference to it.
And we'll see a lot
about that.
So let me tell you about
environments.
I need the overhead projection
machine, thank you.
And so here is a bunch of
environment structures.
An environment is a way of doing
substitutions virtually.
It represents a place where
something is stored which is
the substitutions that
you haven't done.
It's a place where everything
accumulates, where the names
of the variables are associated
with the values
they have such that when you
say, what dose this name mean,
you look it up in
an environment.
So an environment is a function,
or a table, or
something like that.
But it's a structured
sort of table.
It's made out of things
called frames.
Frames are pieces of
environment, and they are
chained together, in some nice
ways, by what's called parent
links or something like that.
So here, we have an environment
structure
consisting of three
environments,
basically, a, b, and c.
d is also an environment, but
it's the same one, they share.
And that's the essence
of assignment.
If I change a variable, a value
of a valuable that lives
here, like that one, it should
be visible from all places
that you're looking
at it from.
Take this one, x.
If I change the x to four, it's
visible from other places.
But I'm not going to worry
about that right now.
We're going to talk a lot about
that in a little while.
What do we have here?
Well, these are called frames.
Here is a frame, here's a frame,
and here's a frame.
a is an environment which
consists of the table which is
frame two, followed by the
table labeled frame one.
And, in this environment, in
say this environment, frame
two, x and y are bound.
They have values.
Sorry, in frame one--
In frame two, z is bound, and
x is bound, and y is bound,
but the value of x that we see,
looking from this point
of view, is this x.
It's x is seven, rather than
this one which is three.
We say that this x
shadows this x.
From environment three--
from frame three, from
environment b, which refers to
frame three, we have variables
n and y bound and also x.
This y shadow this one.
So the value, looking
from this point of
view, of y is two.
The value for looking
from this point of
view and m is one.
And the value, looking
from this point of
view, of x is three.
So there we have a very
simple environment
structure made out of frames.
These correspond to the
applications of procedures.
And we'll see that
in a second.
So now I have to make you some
other nice little structure
that we build.
Next slide, we see an object,
which I'm going to draw
procedures.
This is a procedure.
A procedure is made
out of two parts.
It's sort of like a cons.
However, it's the two parts.
The first part refers to some
code, something that can be
executed, a set of instructions,
if you will.
You can think of it that way.
And the second part is
the environment.
The procedure is the
whole thing.
And we're going to have to use
this to capture the values of
the free variables that occur
in the procedure.
If a variable occurs in the
procedure it's either bound in
that procedure or free.
If it's bound, then the value
will somehow be easy to find.
It will be in some easy
environment to get at.
If it's free, we're going to
have to have something that
goes with the procedure that
says where we'll go
look for its value.
And the reasons why are not
obvious yet, but will be soon.
So here's a procedure object.
It's a composite object
consisting of a piece of code
and a environment structure.
Now I will tell you the new
rules, the complete new rules,
for evaluation.
The first rule is-- there's
only two of them.
These correspond to the
substitution model rules.
And the first one has to do
with how do you apply a
procedure to its arguments?
And a procedural object is
applied to a set of arguments
by constructing a new frame.
That frame will contain the
mapping of the former
parameters to the actual
parameters of the arguments
that were supplied
in the call.
As you know, when we make up
a call to a procedure like
lambda x times x y, and we call
that with the argument
three, then we're going
to need some
mapping of x to three.
It's the same thing as later
substituting, if you will, the
three for the x in
the old model.
So I'm going to build a frame
which contains x equals three
as the information
in that frame.
Now, the body of the procedure
will then have to be evaluated
which is this.
I will be evaluated in an
environment which is
constructed by adjoining the new
frame that we just made to
the environment which
was part of the
procedure that we applied.
So I'm going to make a little
example of that here.
Supposing I have some
environment.
Here's a frame which
represents it.
And some procedure-- which I'm
going to draw with circles
here because it's easier
than little triangles--
Sorry, those are rhombuses,
rhomboidal little pieces of
fruit jelly or something.
So here's a procedure which
takes this environment.
And the procedure has a piece
of code, which is a lambda
expression, which binds x and
y and then executes an
expression, e.
And this is the procedure.
We'll call it p.
I wish to apply that procedure
to three and four.
So I want to do p of
three and four.
What I'm going to do, of course,
is make a new frame.
I build a frame which contains
x equals three,
and y equals four.
I'm going to connect that frame
to this frame over here.
And then this environment, with
I will call b, is the
environment in which I will
evaluate the body of e.
Now, e may contain references
to x and y and other things.
x and y will have values
right here.
Other things will have
their values here.
How do we get this frame?
That we do by the construction
of procedures which is the
other rule.
And I think that's
the next slide.
Rule two, when a lambda
expression is evaluated,
relative to a particular
environment--
See, the way I get a procedure
is by evaluating the lambda
expression.
Here's a lambda expression.
By evaluating it, I get
a procedure which I
can apply to three.
Now this lambda expression is
evaluated in an environment
where y is defined.
And I want the body of
this which contains a
free version of y.
y is free in here, it's bound
over the whole thing, but it's
free over here.
I want that y to be this one.
I evaluate this body of this
procedure in the environment
where y was created.
That's this kind of thing,
because that was done by
application.
Now, if I ever want to look up
the value of y, I have to know
where it is.
Therefore, this procedural was
created, the creation of the
procedure which is the result
of evaluating that lambda
expression had better capture
a pointer or remember the
frame in which y was bound.
So that's what this rule
is telling us.
So, for example, if I happen
to be evaluating a lambda
expression, lambda expression in
e, lambda of say, x and y,
let's call it g in e,
evaluating that.
Well, all that means is I now
construct a procedure object.
e is some environment.
e is something which has
a pointer to it.
I construct a procedure object
that points up to that
environment, where the code of
that is a lambda expression or
whatever that translates into.
And this is the procedure.
So this produces for me-- this
object here, this environment
pointer, captures the place
where this lambda expression
was evaluated, where the
definition was used, where the
definition was used to make a
procedure, to make the procedure.
So it picks up the environment
from the place where that
procedure was defined, stores
it in the procedure itself,
and then when the procedure is
used, the environment where it
was defined is extended
with the new frame.
So this gives us a locus
for putting where a
variable has a value.
And, for example, if there are
lots of guys pointing in at
that environment, then they
share that place.
And we'll see more
of that shortly.
Well, now you have a new model
for understanding the
execution of programs. I suppose
I'll take questions
now, and then we'll go on and
use that for something.
AUDIENCE: Is it right to say
then, the environment is that
linked chain of frames--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: starting with--
working all the way back?
PROFESSOR: Yes, the environment
is a sequence of
frames linked together.
And the way I like to think
about it, it's the pointer to
the first one, because
once you've got that
you've got them all.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Is it possible to
evaluate a procedure or to
define a procedure in two
different environments such
that it will behave
differently, and
have pointers to both--
PROFESSOR: Oh, yes.
The same procedure is not going
to have two different
environments.
The same code, the same lambda
expression can be evaluated in
two environments producing
two different procedures.
Each procedure--
AUDIENCE: Their definition
has the same name.
Their operation--
PROFESSOR: The definition is
written the same, with the
same characters.
I can evaluate that set of
characters, whatever, that
list structure that defines,
that is the textual
representation.
I can evaluate that in two
different environments
producing two different
procedures.
Each of those procedures has
its own local sets of
variables, and we'll
see that right now.
Anybody else?
OK, thank you.
Let's take a break.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well, now I've done this
terrible thing to you.
I've introduced a very
complicated thing, assignment,
which destroys most of the
interesting mathematical
properties of our programs. Why
should I have done this?
What possible good
could this do?
Clearly not a nice thing, so I
better have a good excuse.
Well, let's do a little bit of
playing, first of all, with
some very interesting programs
that have assignment.
Understand something special
about them that makes them
somewhat valuable.
Start with a very simple program
which I'm going to
call make-counter.
I'm going to define make-counter
to be a procedure
of one argument n which
returns as its value a
procedure of no arguments--
a procedure that produces
a procedure--
which sets n to the increment
of n and returns
that value of n.
Now we're going to investigate
the behavior of this.
It's a sort of interesting
thing.
In order to investigate the
behavior, I have to make an
environment model, because
we can't understand
this any other way.
So let's just do that.
We start out with
some sort of--
let's say there is a global
environment that the machine
is born with.
Global we'll call it.
And it's going to have in it
a bunch of initial things.
We all know what it's got.
It's got things in it like
say, plus, and times, and
quotient, and difference,
and CAR, and et
cetera, lots of things.
I don't know what they are, some
various squiggles that
are the things the machine
is born with.
And by doing the definition
here, what I plan to do--
Well, what am I doing?
I'm doing this relative to
the global environment.
So here's my environment
pointer.
In order to do that I have
to evaluate this lambda
expression.
That means I make a
procedure object.
So I'm going to make a procedure
object here.
And the procedure object has, as
the place it's defined, the
global environment.
The procedure object contains
some code that represents a
procedure of one argument n
which returns a procedure of
no arguments which
does something.
And the define is a way of
changing this environment, so
that I now add to it a
make-counter, a special rule
for the special thing defined.
But what that is, is
it gives me that
pointer to that procedure.
So now the global environment
contains make-counter as well.
Now, we're going to do
some operations.
I'm going to use this to
make some counters.
We'll see what a counter is.
So let's define c1 to be a
counter beginning at 0.
Well, we know how to do this
now, according to the model.
I have to evaluate the
expression make-counter in the
global environment,
make-counter of 0.
Well, I look up make-counter and
see that it's a procedure.
I'm going to have to apply
that procedure.
The way I apply the procedure
is by constructing a frame.
So I construct a frame which has
a value for n in it which
is 0, and the parent environment
is the one which
is the environment of definition
of make-counter.
So I've made an environment by
applying make-counter to 0.
Now, I have to evaluate the body
of make-counter, which is
this lambda expression,
in that environment.
Well evaluating this body,
this body is a lambda
expression.
Evaluate a lambda expression
means make a procedure object.
So I'm going to make
a procedure object.
And that procedure object has
the environment it was defined
in being that, where n
was defined to be 0.
And it has some code, which is
the procedure of no arguments
which does something, that sets
something, and returns n.
And this thing is going to be
the object, which in the
global environment, will
have the name c1.
So we construct a name here, c1,
and say that equals that.
Now, but also make another
counter, c2 to be make-counter
say, starting with 10.
Then I do essentially
the same thing.
I apply the make-counter
procedure, which I got from
here, to make another frame
with n being 10.
That frame has the global
environment as its parent.
I then construct a procedure
which has that as it's frame
of definition.
The code of it is the procedure
of no arguments
which does something.
And it does a set, and so on.
And n comes out.
And c2 is this.
Well, you're already beginning
to see something fairly
interesting.
There are two n's here.
They are not one n.
Each time I called make-counter,
I made another
instance of n.
These are distinct and separate
from each other.
Now, let's do some execution,
use those counters.
I'm going to use
those counters.
Well, what happens if I
say, c1 at this point?
Well, I go over here,
and I say, oh
yes, c1 is a procedure.
I'm going to call this procedure
on no arguments, but
it has no parameters.
That's right.
What's its body?
Well, I have to look over
here, because I
didn't write it down.
It said, set n to one plus n
and return n, increment n.
Well, the n it sees
is this one.
So I increment that n.
That becomes one, and I
return the value one.
Supposing I then called c2.
Well, what do I do?
I say c2 is this procedure which
does the same thing, but
here's the n.
It becomes 11.
And so I have an 11 which
is the value.
I then can say, let's
try c1 again.
c1 is this, that's two,
so the answer is two.
And c2 gives me a 12 by the same
method, by walking down
here looking at that and saying,
here's the n, I'm
incrementing.
So what I have are computational
objects.
There are two counters,
each with its own
independent local state.
Let's talk about
this a little.
This is a strange thing.
What's an object?
It's not at all obvious
what an object is.
We like to think about
objects, because it's
economical to think that way.
It's an intellectual economy.
I am an object.
You are an object.
We are not the same object.
I can divide the world into
two parts, me and you, and
there's other things as well,
such that most of the things I
might want to discuss about my
workings do not involve you,
and most of the things I want to
discuss about your workings
don't involve me.
I have a blood pressure, a
temperature, a respiration
rate, a certain amount of
sugar in my blood, and
numerous, thousands, of state
variables-- millions actually,
or I don't know how many--
huge numbers of state variables
in the physical
sense which represent the state
of me as a particle, and
you have gazillions
of them as well.
And most of mine are uncoupled
to most of yours.
So we can compute the properties
of me without
worrying too much about
the properties of you.
If we had to work about both
of us together, than the
number of states that we have to
consider is the product of
the number of states you have
and the number of states I
have. But this way it's
almost a sum.
Now, indeed there are forces
that couple us.
I'm talking to you and
your state changes.
I'm looking at you and
my state changes.
Some of my state variables, a
very few of them, therefore,
are coupled to yours.
If you were to suddenly yell
very loud, my blood pressure
would go up.
However, and it may not be
always appropriate to think
about the world as being made
out of independent states and
independent particles.
Lots of the bugs that occur in
things like quantum mechanics,
or the bugs in our minds that
occur when we think about
things like quantum mechanics,
are due the fact that we are
trying to think about things
being broken up into
independent pieces, when in
fact there's more coupling
than we see on the surface, or
that we want to believe in,
because we want to compute
efficiently and effectively.
We've been trained to
think that way.
Well, let's see.
How would we know if we
had objects at all?
How can we tell if
we have objects?
Consider some possible
optical illusions.
This could be done.
These pieces of chalk are not
appropriately identical, but
supposing you couldn't tell
the difference of them by
looking at them.
Well, there's a possibility
that this all a game I'm
playing with mirrors.
It's really the same piece
of chalk, but you're
seeing two of them.
How would you know if you're
seeing one or two?
Well, there's only
one way I know.
You grab one of them and change
it and see if the other
one changed.
And it didn't, so there's
two of them.
And, on the other hand, there
is some other screwy
properties of things
like that.
Like, how do we know if
something changed?
We have to look at it before
and after the change.
The change is an assignment,
it's a moment in time.
But that means we have to know
it was the same one that we're
looking at.
So some very strange, and
unusual, and obscure, and--
I don't understand the problems
associated with
assignment, and change,
and objects.
These could get very,
very bad.
For example, here I am, I am
a particular person, a
particular object.
Now, I can take out my knife,
and cut my fingernail.
A piece of my fingernail has
fallen off onto the table.
I believe I am the same person
I was a second ago, but I'm
not physically the same
in the slightest.
I have changed.
Why am I the same?
What is the identity of me?
I don't know.
Except for the fact that I have
some sort of identity.
And so, I think by introducing
assignment and objects, we
have opened ourselves up to all
the horrible questions of
philosophy that have been
plaguing philosophers for some
thousands of years about
this sort of thing.
It's why mathematics
is a lot cleaner.
Let's look at the best things
I know to say about actions
and identity.
We say that an action, a, had an
effect on an object, x, or
equivalently, that x was
changed by a, if some
property, p, which was true
of x before a, became
false of x after a.
Let's test. It still means
I have to have the
x before and after.
Or, the other way of saying
this is, we say that two
objects x and y are the same
for any action which has an
effect on x has the
same effect on y.
However, objects are very
useful, as I said, for
intellectual economy.
One of the things that's
incredibly useful about them,
is that the world is, we like
to think about, made out of
independent objects with
independent local state.
We like to think that
way, although it
isn't completely true.
When we want to make very
complicated programs that deal
with such a world, if we want
those programs to be
understandable by us and also
to be changeable, so that if
we change the world we change
the program only a little bit,
then we want there to be
connections, isomorphism,
between the objects in the world
and the objects in our
mental model.
The modularity of the world can
give us the modularity in
our programming.
So we invent things called
object-oriented programming
and things like that to provide
us with that power.
But it's even easier.
Let's play a little game.
I want to play a little game,
show you an even easier
example of where modularity can
be enhanced by using an
assignment statement,
judiciously.
One thing I want to enforce and
impress on you, is don't
use assignment statements the
way you use it in FORTRAN or
Basic or something or Pascal,
to do the things you don't
have to do with it.
It's not the right way to
think for most things.
Sometimes it's essential,
or maybe it's essential.
We'll see more about that too.
OK, let me show you
a fun game here.
There was mathematician by
the name of Cesaro--
or Cesaro, Cesaro I
suppose it is--
who figured out a clever
way of computing pi.
It turns out that if I take to
random numbers, two integers
at random, and compute the
greatest common divisor, their
greatest common divisor is
either one or it's not one.
If it's one, then they have
no common divisors.
If their greatest common
divisor is one--
the probability that two random
numbers, two numbers
chosen at random, has as
greatest common divisor one is
related to pi.
In fact--
yes, it's very strange--
of course there are other ways
of computing pi, like dropping
pins on flags, and things like
that, and sort of the same
kind of thing.
So the probability of that the
GCD of number one and number
two, two random numbers chosen,
is 6 over pi squared.
I'm not going to try
to prove that.
It's actually not too hard
and sort of fun.
How would we estimate
such probability?
Well, the way we do that, the
way we estimate probabilities,
is by doing lots of experiments,
and then
computing the ratios of the ones
that come out one way to
the total number of
experiments we do.
It's called Monte Carlo, and
it's useful in other contexts
for doing things like integrals
where you have lots
and lots of variables--
the space which is limiting the
dimensions you are doing
you integral in.
But going back to here, Let's
look at this slide, We can use
Cesaro's method for estimating
pi with n trials by taking the
square root of six over a Monte
Carlo, a Monte Carlo
experiment with n trials, using
Cesaro's experiment,
where Cesaro's experiment is the
test of whether the GCD of
two random numbers--
And you can see that I've
already got some assignments
in here, just by what I wrote.
The fact that this word rand,
in parentheses, therefore,
that procedure call, yields a
different value than this one,
at least that's what I'm
assuming by writing this this
way, indicates that this is not
a function, that there's
internal state in it
which is changing.
If the GCD of those two random
numbers is equal to one,
that's the experiment.
So here I have an experimental
method for estimating the
value of pi.
Where, I can easily divide this
problem into two parts.
One is the specific Monte Carlo
experiment of Cesaro,
which you just saw, and the
other is the general technique
of doing Monte Carlo
experiments.
And that's what this is.
If I want to do Monte Carlo
experiments with n trials, a
certain number of trials, and
a particular experiment, the
way I do that is I make a little
iterative procedure
which has variable the number
of trials remaining and the
number trials that have been
passed, that I've gotten true.
And if the number remaining is
0, then the answer is the
number past divided by this
whole number of trials, was
the estimate of the
probability.
And if it's not, if I have
more trials to do,
then let's do one.
We do an experiment.
We call the procedure which is
experiment on no arguments.
We do the experiment and then,
if that turned out to be true,
we go around the loop
decrementing the number of
experiments we have to do by
one and incrementing the
number that were passed.
And if the experiment was false,
we just go around the
loop decrementing the number of
experiments remaining and
keeping the number
passed the same.
We start this up iterating
over the total number of
trials with 0 experiments
past. A very
elegant little program.
And I don't have to just do this
with Cesaro's experiment,
it could be lots of Monte Carlo
experiments I might do.
Of course, this depends upon the
existence of some sort of
random number generator.
And random number generators
generally look
something like this.
There is a random number
generator--
is in fact a procedure which is
going to do something just
like the counter.
It's going to update an x to
the result of applying some
function to x, where this
function is some screwy kind
of function that you might find
out in Knuth's books on
the details of programming.
He does these wonderful books
that are full of the details
of programming, because I can't
remember how to make a
random number generator, but I
can look it up there, and I
can find out.
And then, eventually, I return
the value of x which is the
state variable internal to the
random number generator.
That state variable
is initialized
somehow, and has a value.
And this procedure is defined
in the context where that
variable is bound.
So this is a hidden piece of
local state that you see here.
And this procedure is defined
in that context.
Now, that's a very simple
thing to do.
And it's very nice.
Supposing, I didn't want
to use assignments.
Supposing, I wanted to write
this program without
assignments.
What problems would I have?
Well, let's see.
I'd like to use the overhead
machine here, thank you.
First of all, let's look
at the whole thing.
It's a big story.
Unfortunately, which tells you
there is something wrong.
It's at least that big,
and it's monolithic.
You don't have to understand
or look at the text there
right now to see that
it's monolithic.
It isn't a thing which is
Cesaro's experiment.
It's not pulled out from the
Monte Carlo process.
It's not separated.
Let's look why.
Remember, the constraint here is
that every procedure return
the same value for the
same arguments.
Every procedure represents
a function.
That's a different kind
of constraint.
Because when I have assignments,
I can change some
internal state variable.
So let's see how that causes
things to go wrong.
Well, start at the beginning.
The estimate of pi looks
sort of the same.
What I'm doing is I take the
square root of six over the
random GCD test applied to n,
whereas that's what this is.
But here, we are beginning
to see something funny.
The random GCD test of a certain
number of trials is
just like we had before, an
iteration on the number of
trials remaining, the number
of trials that have been
passed, and another
variable x.
What's that x?
That x is the state of the
random number generator.
And it is now going
to be used here.
The same random update function
that I have over here
is the one I would have used in
a random number generator
if I were building it the other
way, the one I get out
of Knuth's books.
x is going to get transformed
into x1, I
need two random numbers.
And x1 is going to get
transformed into x2, I have
two random numbers.
I then have to do exactly
what I did before.
I take the GCD of x1 x2.
If that's one, then I go around
the loop with x2 being
the next value of x.
You see what's happened here
is that the state of the
random number generator is no
longer confined to the insides
of the random number
generator.
It has leaked out.
It has leaked out into my
procedure that does the Monte
Carlo experiment.
But what's worse than that, is
it's also, because it was
contained inside my experiment
itself, Cesaro, it leaked out
of that too.
Because Cesaro called twice, has
to have a different value
each time, if I going to have
a legitimate experimental
test. So Cesaro can't be a
function either, unless I pass
it the seed of the random number
generator that is going
to go wandering around.
So unfortunately, the seed of
random number generator has
leaked out into Cesaro, from the
random number generator,
that's leaked into the Monte
Carlo experiment.
And, unfortunately, my Monte
Carlo experiment here is no
longer general.
The Monte Carlo experiment here
knows how many random
numbers I need to do
the experiment.
That's sort of horrible.
I lost an ability to decompose a
problem into pieces, because
I wasn't willing to accept the
little loop of information,
the feedback process, that
happens inside the random
number generator before that
was made by having an
assignment to a state variable
that was confined to the
random number generator.
So the fact that the random
number generator is an object,
with an internal state variable,
it's affected by
nothing, but it'll give you
something, and it will apply
it's force to you, that was
what we're missing now.
OK, well I think we've seen
enough reason for doing this,
and it all sort of looks
very wonderful.
Wouldn't it be nice if
assignment was a good thing
and maybe it's worth it,
but I'm not sure.
As Mr. Gilbert and Sullivan
said, things are seldom what
they seem, skim milk masquerades
as cream.
Are there any questions?
Are there any philosophers
here?
Anybody want to argue
about objects?
You're just floored, right?
And you haven't done
your homework yet.
You haven't come up with
a good question.
Oh, well.
Sure, thank you.
Let's take the long break now.